yes i look snack especially when i take
these paparazzi pictures and i'm like
this i really like this guys cardi b
opens up about giving birth to her son
and keeps it real about her post-baby
body i love everything about motherhood
i miss a lot but i love everything the
grammy winner welcomed her second child
with hubby offset on september 4th and
on thursday the proud mom shared a
message with fans who had been praising
her body just weeks after giving birth
people been giving me amazing
compliments on my body
um i think it's because right now i got
some amazing hips to mo due to my
gorgeous son because he was sitting so
low you know when your baby's low your
hips spread but everybody just like
carter you so snatched what did you do
you did light bull you had a tummy tuck
you cannot do surgery
after you give birth especially me i
lost so much blood guys one day i'm
gonna talk to you guys about my crazy
ass delivery cardi's insta story comes
just days after she went all out for her
first red carpet appearance since giving
birth stunning in not one but two
body-hugging ensembles to attend the
moogler exhibition in paris on tuesday
yes that looks especially when i take
these paparazzi pictures and i'm like
this i really like this guys i you know
i like to be real with you guys and
that's because my skin is still loose
and i still got a little pouchy pouch
right here right here and oh
i'll show you my back fat and my face is
still so fat in my neck but
take your time it's written it's really
hard dealing with kids especially when
you do two kids after you give birth
cardi and offset have yet to reveal the
name of their new bundle of joy who is
baby bro to the rapper's daughter
three-year-old culture she's so cute i
love her the [ __ ] rapper kept fans clued
in to every stage of pregnancy with her
new little one barbecue sauce barbecue
meat grilled meat is a real fat
craving
baby and when the couple announced the
arrival of their little bundle of joy
they said in part quote we are so
overjoyed to finally meet our son he has
already loved so much
[Music]